senator Tammy Duckworth will soon become
the first senator to give birth while in
office earlier this week she announced
she's expecting her second child she is
almost seven months pregnant now and is
due this spring the 49 year old retired
Army lieutenant colonel lost both legs
while serving in Iraq and she spoke with
Nancy Cordes for Sunday's Face the
Nation about why she chose to open up
about her struggles to conceive it was a
difficult pregnancy the first pregnancy
I'm conceiving Abigail it took me almost
10 years of trying in three years of IVF
but with this baby I ended up having a
miscarriage and and and multiple cycles
again and I just wanted to be honest
because I know that there's so many
families out there struggling with
infertility issues and as as more women
deal with fertility issues and trying to
balance their career and their and and
and their personal lives and put off
pregnancy until later I just I just
wanted people to know that this is a far
more common than people realize and that
we all struggle and what did your doctor
say to you about the chances of getting
pregnant at 49 well he said it's the new
40
so he said 50 50 year-old mom is a new
40 like that you can watch Nancy's
interview with senator Tammy Duckworth
on Face the Nation on Sunday right here
on CBS